so what are you so I can call you sir or
ma'am what are you what would you assume
looking at me no
no did them call you sir I don't know
what they did then because they saw the
name on my credit card and they were
being they were not being nice people
well I mean that's not your name in The
Car Guy what you want what the one what
do you want them to tell you
that has nothing to do with it there
could be someone in the back that they
don't see
that's paying okay man so why would they
intentionally do that can you tell me
what your location has done to be
transcompetent
transcompetent
I guess oh is that because a person is
trans yeah
so if they gave him a name and the name
was like James Corden yeah so they're
like hello sir and they're like actually
it's ma'am
and now they're mad about the fact
we're covering this
laughs
[Laughter]
I mean let me do it
the smell was killing me man
it's not bad it's the way you look at it
I'm disgusting your face
okay like I tell you we don't need to
discriminate anybody in here
okay I'm so sorry if you feel
discriminated no no it's not that I feel
it's that I was discriminated against I
would like you
to promise me no no no no no no no no no
no
[ __ ] says sorry and that's what
it is that's it and the story move I
would like to to prom I got what are you
my mom [ __ ] I don't promise you to my
girlfriend who The [ __ ] You Think You
Are
promise me that yeah promise me to suck
my dick Shut the [ __ ] up and get the
[ __ ] up and move on listen I think it's
perfectly acceptable if somebody gets
whatever pronoun just let him know and
then after that they character whatever
just move on exactly here yelling with
these people promise me it's just more
damage to whatever it's just a waste of
time it already went oh way over they
apologize and you still push it yeah it
looks like okay this is something more
than what it needs that's the thing
that's that they apologize that is that
is everybody
everybody every Community that's been
ostracized that's been uh
uh you're gonna feel some type of way
and when things are things are going to
happen you're gonna do a little bit more
that's that happens with black people
and racism that happen with big people
and with the fat people that happen with
trans people that happen with gays that
person says sorry hey sorry
but then that's not enough
you want more now I want you to promise
okay now that you promise I want you to
get down on your knees and tell me
pretty please yeah it's never enough at
some point and I don't my community went
through that [ __ ]
we went through that [ __ ] we were doing
the most sometimes and I was like yo
this is not solving anything right now
and the person said sorry move on or
never shop there again vote and make
people decide what your dollars once a
car once someone is going to realize
that you're not spending so much money
on a place they're gonna change their
ways and that's it yeah it's gonna be
for the money sometimes that's how you
get people to change their mind yup
crazy isn't it I know [ __ ] up isn't it
but I wanted to come from them yeah but
you're not you cannot decide that for
someone okay let's give it a sec if you
got a name like James Corden people are
gonna assume you're a sir
and if you do not understand that I got
a friend I got a friend she's a girl her
name is Fred
yeah their parents name their dick you
cannot beat Frederick
you cannot be mad at your name is Fred
and people think or assume that sure got
if you don't understand that
then you're being a bit disingenuous
you're you're being you're not being
you're not being real with yourself
right now
come on now B
that you will stop treating trans people
this way I'm training you I'm treating
you bad
and I'm doing your staff did you name it
the credit card
it's a feminine name
no exactly they're not discriminating
yes they are they're not
coming from a store
you get the reason why a store clerk is
gonna ask you for is because they get
frauded a lot that's it
it's monetary it's not trans or whatever
[ __ ] most [ __ ] don't
care
yo your name don't match we get frauds
out here we want to see if it match
they're gonna sometimes ask you for ID
that's it that's it you're trying to
make a thing out of a thing that's not a
thing yeah my sexuality whatever it is
and I feel confident
talking about sexuality you don't even
know what we're talking about so how can
you tell me I don't know what I'm
talking about we're talking about gender
identity you are talking about sexuality
okay to me
I'm a male
okay okay so what are you so I can call
you sir or ma'am what are you what would
you assume looking at me no no
no no no no no
you're not doing this
no no so you're asking him that's a trap
he asked you what you would prefer and
then you asked him what do I look like
Jesus [ __ ] Christ and you're gonna be
what are you gonna answer you're gonna
be like oh you're [ __ ] bigot if you
don't get the [ __ ] out of here bro if
you do not take all your [ __ ] all them
pictures the plaque this [ __ ]
[ __ ] right here and get the [ __ ] out of
here
see that's what I was like I don't want
to cover this [ __ ] because I I could
smell I could feel how dumb that [ __ ]
was this [ __ ] is a whole this [ __ ] right
here you see it right here right here
this [ __ ] my [ __ ] this [ __ ] right here
this [ __ ] right here this [ __ ] this [ __ ]
right here is a whole ass set up my dude
let's go what are you what would you
assume looking at me
I assume that you're a man
okay
[Music]
thank you
oh [ __ ]
oh
[ __ ]
listen my girl
that reveal did not I don't know you
thought you're like hey uh you activated
my trap card everybody that was your
trap card everybody's going to jail
everybody's going to the hell right now
cause [ __ ]
I'm not looking I'm not looking I
already look once all right I'm not
doing it delicious listen listen
who cares what people believe just ask
ask them what they ask you what do you
want me to call you just tell them so
they can call you what you want to be
called and let's keep it pushing stop
trying to change everybody's mind stop
talking people see Hey listen
no
no that's enough
that's it's not happy
you know what pisses me off
that's not the majority of trans people
absolutely that's not the majority of
friends absolutely there's and that's a
[ __ ] up thing is that there's a couple
of people like that that derailed the
whole discussion the real discussion
that we're supposed to have and the rail
what's really going on and makes
everybody in that category look bad
that's not that's not all trans people
that's that's not them
um
not all man not all trans also you know
I think a lot of folks are online all
the time and so they expect everybody to
be like up to date on all this lingo and
everything else happening it's just not
the case yep from My Friends by other
people in my family like none of these
people know about any of this stuff so
if I would have asked them what does
this person look like to y'all it would
have probably said something similar so
you have to understand where people are
at with this conversation and and coming
at it from any other perspective is a
losing battle because you're convinced
the world is supposed to be a one-way
based off your online interactions or
whatever the [ __ ] it might be reality is
just completely different like I said
this person is actually far more
Progressive than a lot of other people I
know because this person said what would
you like to be called
instead of just telling them what you
want and then they can do it you try to
do a whole switch you try to get to the
root of like what they think and
everything else like yo just keep it
pushing bro I'm not out here talking to
store clerks trying to solve their
internal race like it is what it is just
be respectful of me when I'm in your
store and I'll be respected with you and
I don't need to know all your [ __ ]
personal views I don't even need you to
agree with me let's just get this [ __ ]
right not here to go send you the
sensitivity training that's not what you
hear do your transactions and [ __ ] be
gone if somebody got your pronoun
whatever wrong because your name is
James Corden whatever the [ __ ] it is
like if I keep my brain James Cordon
he's stealing jokes we're stealing his
name wow you stole Ricky Gervais because
yeah there you go so yeah just just keep
it pushing I don't I don't get this one
you know what's [ __ ] up and then she
did the whole face reveal that [ __ ] did
not work in your favor that's crazy
because you said just do your
transaction and I was like well
technically that was a transaction
anyways yeah maybe that you guys don't
appreciate that one
folks got mad at me last time I didn't
appreciate your joke the beat around the
bush one that's not even okay can we can
we explain that one uh that's not a joke
that's just me talking that's how I talk
you can't he can't always he can't
always he can't always stop at every
dumb [ __ ] I say you have to understand
once this camera is off I continue to
say dumb [ __ ] and and we work together
so he's there for that right so we
there's sometimes he's like he
understood what I said he is like yeah
yeah cool we heard you [ __ ] moving on
he's got [ __ ] to say he can't
acknowledge every dumb [ __ ] I say I say
quite a lot but anyways all that to say
yeah huh